the easiest way to improve your
storytelling is to remove the distance
between you and the story we call this
layers of abstraction how in the moment
are you when you're telling the story
the beginner will be in the highest
level of abstraction they'll say things
like you know how sometimes we go into
these ruts in life and it just feels
kind of terrible and we don't know what
to do that's so hypothetical we do that
we have no idea what they're talking
about a second layer of abstraction when
they start giving you more detail like
you know how sometimes we get fired from
the job and we just like don't know what
to do it's so hard finding a job and
like that's getting closer to
storytelling they're actually telling
you some of the content but there's
still a distance for what they're
actually trying to do where the real
story is man I was on the list of
layoffs and I found out the other day
that I'm not gonna keep my job it sucks
it's that type of Storytelling where
you're actually embodying the moment
you're not creating any abstraction or
any distance between yourself and the
story